[Music]
putin's invasion of ukraine has led
western countries to enact truly
unprecedented sanctions russia is now
under an immense amount of economic
pressure but putin knew this would
happen and he still decided to invade so
he must have had a plan to evade these
sanctions and keep the russian economy
going during the war well the obvious
answer is just use crypto russian
officials are now looking at
cryptocurrency crypto is looking like it
could potentially be an escape hatch on
top of everything else awful about putin
he's also into crypto but the situation
isn't quite so simple putin's plan to
fund his war is extremely complex after
all he's been planning this invasion for
years now so let's dig into how russia
is dealing with western sanctions one
step at a time
[Music]
war is pain the images coming out of
ukraine right now are horrifying
and i want nothing more than a swift and
peaceful end to this conflict i fully
support ukrainian independence and will
be donating the profits from this video
to unicef i also want to be clear that
the responsibility for this tragedy lies
with vladimir putin millions of russian
citizens are against this war and i
support anyone who works towards peace
now before we get to putin's crypto
strategy we need to investigate russia's
key economic assets we live in an
increasingly globalized world where
countries are deeply interconnected this
interdependence usually acts as a
stabilizing factor since going to war
with a trade partner risks destabilizing
the entire global economy but putin
doesn't really care about this because
russia has built up so many strong local
industries they have a reliable
agricultural sector that provides food
for the population they also have a
significant technology sector that helps
with cyber security and cyber espionage
and of course they have tons of natural
resources this allows putin to act with
more impunity than other leaders because
he's less dependent on other countries
unfortunately the same can't be said
about most european countries which rely
on russia for natural gas putin's energy
industry is an incredible source of
power russian natural gas helps heat
european houses during the winter and
there isn't a great alternative at the
moment that's why european countries
have been trying to exclude the energy
sector from russian sanctions they
really need russian natural gas see back
in 1969 germany implemented a policy
called ostpolitique which aimed to
intertwine the german and russian
economies by building a network of gas
pipelines germany and russia would
become reliable trading partners and be
less likely to attack one another at
least that was the plan the problem is
that europe has become overly dependent
on russian natural gas and putin knows
that now many european countries do have
plans to eliminate the use of natural
gas but it's going to take decades for
example the netherlands wants to get off
of natural gas by 2050 but that won't
have a meaningful impact on the current
situation in ukraine and other efforts
to diversify away from natural gas are
struggling in 2011 germany had 17
nuclear power plants and they were
working really well but after japan's
fukushima disaster germany started
shutting them down now they only have
three in operation and these are
scheduled to shut down by the end of the
year europe needs natural gas and
putin's hope is that they will keep
buying it from him no matter how bad the
situation gets in ukraine but there are
still a few ways to fight back
first europe could start importing more
natural gas from other countries poland
already gets natural gas from australia
and the united states is starting to
generate enough surplus gas to reliably
export it solar energy could also
provide enough clean energy to europe to
meet the energy shortfall but installing
new solar panels is a slow process now
to be clear solar energy is cleaner than
natural gas but natural gas is still
cleaner than oil and coal and we might
not be able to aim for 100 renewable
energy in the short term the crisis is
so serious right now that european
countries will likely try every possible
solution this will put pressure on putin
in the long term but in the short term
he'll still have tons of economic
sanctions to deal with head on these
economic sanctions typically take one of
three forms first restrictions on
powerful russian citizens who support
putin lots of rich wealthy russians have
assets in foreign countries and if
sanctions start making it harder for
them to live their lives they might give
putin a call and tell them to back off
historically these types of sanctions
haven't been very effective but it is
one option the second option is to stop
russian banks from doing business with
western countries preventing these banks
from making international payments will
slow down economic activity and make it
harder for the russian economy to keep
funding the war in ukraine lastly
sanctions on russia's central bank could
hurt the ruble and make it harder for
putin to stabilize inflation in russia
these sanctions are already rolling out
and they're wreaking havoc on russian
financial markets but putin has a plan
to fight back and crypto is just one
small piece of the puzzle putin knows
how dependent europe is on natural gas
so he always has the option of cutting
off the supply but that would probably
hurt russia more than europe so that's a
bit of a last resort currently putin
seems focused on stabilizing the russian
economy using internal tools he's raised
interest rates to keep lenders happy
implemented capital controls so that
citizens can't leave with their money
and announced a backstop so russian
companies don't need to worry about
bankruptcy the world has cut russia off
from the swift network which limits
their ability to transfer money
internationally but there are
alternatives after all the swift network
is merely a messaging system that tells
banks where to move money you can still
pick up the phone and essentially
accomplish the same thing although it's
a lot slower there are still other
payment networks that could replace
swift like china's cips network and of
course we still need to discuss how
crypto fits into all of this even though
these sanctions have been implemented
quickly and are extremely harsh putin
has been preparing for them for years
he's built a massive war chest worth 650
billion dollars that will keep russia
going even in the face of extreme
restrictions internationally 650 billion
dollars is a lot of money but what's
more interesting is how putin has
diversified his holdings see most
countries hold about 60 percent of their
reserve assets in u.s dollars the u.s
dollar is widely accepted as the global
reserve currency and has been stable for
decades so it makes sense to hold a lot
of them but putin knew that his
relationship with america could sour at
any moment and consequently limited his
dollar holdings to just 16 of total
assets the rest of his war chest is
split across gold euros chinese one and
other foreign currencies it took years
to build up but putin was able to
increase the size of his war chest by 70
since 2015. during that time he had to
sacrifice economic growth and hold off
on investing in new initiatives but it
put him in a great position to invade a
neighboring country
see back in 2014 russia annexed crimea
that was basically a test run for the
full ukrainian invasion of 2022 and
putin learned a lot from his experience
in 2014 the crimea conflict led to
sanctions which caused a financial
crisis and led to inflation rates of 16
putin had built up a reserve of foreign
currencies but it wasn't quite big
enough to counteract the international
pressures so the russian economy still
suffered this time around putin knew
that he would need absolutely massive
foreign currency reserves to defend the
ruble from selling pressure as russian
currency starts to drop putin will be
able to buy rubles on the open market
using his war chest of foreign
currencies to stabilize prices and
having a well-stocked currency reserve
will also help keep russian businesses
afloat as these businesses get cut off
from international financial markets
they will still be able to conduct
business with the russian central bank
this is only possible because russia now
has the fifth largest pile of foreign
currency despite being only the 11th
largest economy putin is punching way
above his weight class his foreign
currency reserves aren't untouchable
though the new sanctions will make it
difficult for russia to sell foreign
assets internationally and if any of
those assets are stored in foreign banks
located in unfriendly countries those
assets could be frozen completely but
it's much harder to freeze assets that
are stored in cryptocurrency and that's
why so many people are worried that
putin will leverage crypto to get around
these sanctions what good is kicking
russia out of the swift network if putin
can just use bitcoin to move billions of
dollars around the globe well it might
actually be harder for putin to do this
than most people think let's start with
some basics putin's war chest is 650
billion dollars all of the bitcoin in
the world is currently valued around 830
billion dollars so he would effectively
have to buy all of it and i know that
there are tons of bitcoin holders out
there who will basically never sell but
let's assume that putin wanted to move
into bitcoin and people were willing to
sell could he actually do it bitcoin is
really on the global stage right now
russian leaders may be turning to other
approaches including cryptocurrency
exchanges are seeing a surge in demand
out of russia and ukraine putin might be
out of luck for a few reasons first the
market for turning russian rubles into
bitcoin is extremely thin currently you
can only exchange the equivalent of
around 200 000 at a time this is way too
low to be meaningful to putin's
operation which most analysts believe
needs around 50 billion dollars per day
in liquidity then there's the issue of
actually using crypto exchanges even
though russia can't easily be banned
from the bitcoin blockchain unilaterally
they can be restricted from using
exchanges that do business in western
countries see in order for u.s sanctions
to take effect they need to be
authorized by the president in an
executive order or by congress in
legislation once the sanctions are
approved the office of foreign assets
control designates specific targets by
name these can be governments companies
or even individuals these sanctioned
names are then added to a black list
which makes it illegal for any u.s
citizen to transact with them this is
important because even if a
cryptocurrency exchange wanted to do
business with someone on the blacklist
it would be illegal for them to do so
now it's certainly possible that someone
would be willing to take that risk and
sell cryptocurrency to putin anyway but
the market for these illegal
transactions is much smaller and
interestingly because the blockchain is
public it's actually fairly easy to
track down exactly where money is moving
even though bitcoin was infamous for its
use by criminals a few years ago that's
changing now there are now know your
transaction tools that let companies
know when blacklisted entities try to
use their services you don't have to
look hard to see that it's becoming more
difficult for criminals to launder large
amounts of cryptocurrency just a few
weeks ago there was a major story about
a pair of influencers who tried to
launder billions of dollars worth of
bitcoin and couldn't do it now obviously
they didn't have anywhere near the
sophistication of the russian government
but the story demonstrates how it's
becoming much more difficult to launder
cryptocurrency so if putin can't
accumulate a meaningful amount of crypto
through traditional means and he also
can't build crypto reserves through the
black market what are his options well
he could steal it and this is actually
already happening ransomware is one of
the most common ways for criminals to
acquire cryptocurrency hackers load up
the victim's computer with software that
encrypts critical data then in order to
unlock the data the victim has to send
the hacker bitcoin this is becoming more
and more of a problem and russian
hackers were able to capture 74 of
global ransomware revenue last year but
this won't solve putin's problems even
though russia leads the world in
ransomware attacks they only generated
400 million dollars certainly a massive
amount of money but not nearly enough to
fund a war effort even though it's clear
that putin would love to use crypto to
evade sanctions it doesn't look like he
can and that's why the united states
treasury department said that they
weren't overly worried about crypto
undermining the effort to choke off
putin's access to capital the scale of
what russia needs to move is just not
compatible with the current crypto
markets and putin actually said that he
wasn't interested in using
cryptocurrency for international energy
transactions back in 2021. we obviously
shouldn't take anything that he says at
face value but if putin did think that
crypto would be his sanction escape
hatch wouldn't he have started to
accumulate crypto years ago crypto is an
incredibly controversial issue there's a
lot to love about it and there's a lot
to hate about it but one thing is clear
crypto probably won't be helping putin
anytime soon but it can help the people
of ukraine there are now official
bitcoin and ethereum addresses where you
can send donations the addresses have
been verified and millions have been
donated already one of the most
promising aspects of crypto is how it
allows organizations to collect money
from all over the world more quickly
it's still early days so if you want to
learn more about how one team raised 47
million dollars in just a few days watch
this video next thanks a lot
[Music]